you guys what's up it is prestige and
today is a day where looks like we have
some sad bitter sweet i'll note avenues
today all you might notice i'm so much
sam jackson skin you kind of awkward for
the my hair in series but whatever today
is the day where i announced that the
urban series is coming to and close so i
just wanted to give it in the big happy
tower so maybe i lifted your moved a
little bits if you would like the series
don't back up okay there we go and if
I've all right now the urban series it's
been a great series I've really enjoyed
it and I've done a lot made house over
there then when all Devon came over here
went divine survival for like 17
episodes then we got up to the 25th
episode which was my last episode like
previous episode of the hair brand
experience just straight up the urban
experience and that was pretty great and
I do appreciate all the support you guys
are giving me I know a lot of you guys
came over from the joepassgaming since
he quit YouTube and he had a big series
of the hair burning of the same title
even though he was mainly a pocket
edition guy idea so it's been a great
world and it's been a ton of fun doing
the series I will do my best to keep
doing minecraft series for the future I
don't know I'm probably going to start
another minecraft series or do random
minecraft videos probably still going to
keep going to do keep keep going to be
doing this mod spotlights and yeah I put
all my stuff in the chest just so it may
look all nice and I hear my all my chest
I'm not really going to do any big
explosion on my chest basically the same
stuff what the magma not vanilla goods
chest so we weird like missing all of my
quo where all my stuff go here know what
the where's home
I the heck what is this oh it says heron
Oh looks like our buddy gave us good one
day was good farewell present well heron
wherever you are thank you neither use
my supplies click on your own you can
make them bro come on but this is
something I guess well looks like we're
going to give you keeping this in on the
world urban elastic mark of the series
and yeah so guys I do hope you have
enjoyed the series this is like the
first time I've ever ended like a route
uh this is the first series on my
channel there's a really big thing I got
really into and I thank you every single
one of you for all the support and I
guess just we'll see where we go from
here the first time I've ended a series
like that I really intense like not
intensely but I cared about a lot like
divine RPG I just kind of like a towards
it but herebut experience I've been
doing since like the start of my channel
pretty much so I do hope you guys have
had a great run up to now we're up to
like 460 some subs and yeah so I hope
you enjoyed this video if you did make
sure you leave a like or a comment or
subscribe and the future is gonna be
smexy
the sky
look at that boom